as Ukraine presses its counter-offensive
against Russian occupying forces in the
South Moscow is doing some nuclear
muscle flexing conducting military
exercises simulating response to a
nuclear attack and accusing Kiev of
planning to launch one
Russian forces in the southern region
around her son have been moving injured
people and civilians out of the city but
it's unclear whether the troops
themselves are bracing for battle or
preparing to flee meanwhile Moscow
claims kiev's getting ready to detonate
a dirty bomb laced with radioactive
material a charge Ukrainian leaders deny
saying Russia's describing its own
intentions so on to the point we're
asking the ruse with the dirty bomb a
sign of Putin's weakness
[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to to the point it is
a great pleasure to greet our guests
Jessica Berlin is a geostrategic expert
with the German Marshall fund Gustav
gressel is senior policy fellow and
Military expert at the Berlin office of
the European Council on Foreign
Relations and joining us online from
Bonn is my Ukrainian colleague Roman
godzarenko he's working for DW's Russia
desk
and Roman I'd like to go uh to straight
away to the situation in Hassan because
there's mixed signals emanating from
that region where Russian occupiers uh
have at the same time been sending dire
messages and about an impending
Ukrainian attack and at the same time
also appear to be digging in bracing for
battle so can you give us your
assessment of what is going on there and
also of why Hassan is so strategically
important
well let me start with this uh late um
latest the point that you've mentioned
uh Hassan is extremely important for
both sides it's important for Russia
because
um it is the only point in Ukraine which
Russia managed to well manage Russia
managed to cross the nipro river the
biggest river in Ukraine which divides
the country in two halves in east and
west and it is very difficult to cross
it's a natural barrier and Russia
managed to cross nipro in the early days
of the invasion and from from this from
this place it is planning to go further
west to towards mikolai which is a
neighboring City and Odessa which is an
extremely important report for Ukraine
on the Black Sea and um if Russia
succeeds Ukraine would lose access to
the Black Sea so it is extremely
important for Russia to hold her Zone to
be on that right Bank of the nipro river
and it is extremely important just from
the opposite side for Ukraine to to get
it back and uh it is also important
because it's very close to Crimea to the
annexed Crimea or where Russia m is uh
is getting supplies with fresh water
from that nipple River it is also from
the region of her son so it is it is um
the focal point of this war for both
sides
just just shortly I think we are we are
at a point where Ukraine would like to
um continue its offensive which it
started a few weeks ago or a few months
ago the preparations but it is very slow
and Russia is on the Tipping Point
Russia wants to defend her so not to
lose it and is preparing to defend it
but it could be forced to leave it so
just very quickly if you would when
could the battle for her son take place
because as you say the Ukrainian forces
haven't made real advances in the last
few weeks
well there is a rather small window of
opportunity for Ukraine here
um I think three or four weeks because
the Russian mobilization started in late
September and we'll need some time to
show effect on the battlefield at the
moment ukrainians have a chance to start
the assault on Hassan
um but then that weather and Russian
mobilization could stop Ukraine or make
it more much more difficult to retake
the city so um at the moment we are at a
situation which is very volatile which
very Dynamic and it is impossible to
predict Which side will win in the
coming weeks Gustav the head of
Ukraine's own defense intelligence
agency has downplayed expectations that
or hopes that uh Hassan might soon be
liberated saying that he does not see
the Russians truly preparing to leave is
that just expectation management do you
think or is it realistic no it will be a
hard fight I mean Rush is there are
defensive preparations you see them
taking lines outside of the city you see
them preparing some of the outskirts the
buildings to reinforce them to sustain
shelling and to to basically turn houses
into fortresses on the other side there
are swapping troops there is now one
ponton bridge that operates across the
nipple River it is used for quotation
mark evacuation to have civilians
Crossing that
bridge all the time because as long as
civilians are crossing ukrainians won't
fire at this bridge this bridge then is
also used for military purposes that is
bringing out experienced personal
especially the paratroopers because they
need them elsewhere
and bringing in freshly mobilized uh
fresh troops these fresh troops are of
course weaker less experienced less
tough
but of course they have to perform
static defense that's tactically not
very difficult
um so Russia is supposed to by the way
saying they are cannon fodder of course
they are Russian Russian mobilized
forces are Cannon for that and Russia
will hold this city as long as it can
afford with these troops but on the
other hand they uh they put their Elite
forces elsewhere in order to have again
an operative Reserve to contain
Ukrainian counter offense if that are
expected elsewhere to to follow Jessica
meanwhile Ukrainian president zielinski
is saying that his people should prepare
for what he called the most difficult
winter in their history that hardly
sounds like he's expecting Victory
anytime soon
well the difficulty of this winter goes
far beyond just the battle for Herson as
we've seen in the past weeks Russian
military has been targeting civilian
infrastructure as well as military
targets destroying power plants heating
infrastructure so right now 30 percent
of the countries without power and the
rest of the country is experiencing
planned rolling blackouts to protect the
grid and conserve power and right now
it's October it's getting cold but the
worst the coldest is still of course yet
to come so this will be an incredibly
difficult winter both on the battlefield
but also on the home front and we have
an example of the concerns about the
sensitivity of infrastructure let us
take a closer look now at the situation
in the region around Hassan which Russia
occupied in the early days of the war
and illegally annexed at the end of
September and as we heard just now
Hassan is a strategic prize for whomever
controls it
the Ukrainian counter-offensive in the
south is apparently putting the Russian
occupiers under increasing pressure
images from a Russian State broadcaster
administrators loyal to Moscow are
transporting people from the city of
Kelso across the nipro river they call
it evacuation in anticipation of
Ukrainian attacks Kiev speaks a forced
resettlement Castle is strategically
important if it becomes Ukrainian again
Russia would not be able to advance
further west as planned Ukraine in turn
would Advance toward Crimea
Russian troops west of the nepro have
been in a difficult position for some
time as the Ukrainian Army has destroyed
important supply routes
now the massive kahofka dam is at risk
of becoming a weapon of War
since March the facility has been in the
hands of the Russians Ukraine accuses
them of mining the reservoir and warns
that if it were blown up it would cause
a deadly flash flood for hundreds of
thousands of people the Russian side
claims that it is Ukraine that wants to
blow up the dam itself how we his
Putin's Army in Castle
and let me put that question straight to
Roman we heard uh Gustav telling us just
now that in fact Russia has been
removing some of its most experienced
officers and troops and replacing them
with these newly recruited
inexperienced uh young men what do you
think how long could such forces uh
defend uh occupied Hassan
well it is difficult to assess because
we do not know the whole picture how
many
um are mobilized how many are
experienced of the Russian troops there
from what I hear on Russian State media
there is this feeling that we will not
give up we will not pull back we will
defend her song because it is so much so
important for Russia when you think of
Russian history just to remind you it is
the city which where the Russian Black
Sea fleet was built the first ships were
built there so um it was important in
the 18th 19th century for Russia so uh
you hear such tones some people even
compare harson
the base of the Russian Black Sea Fleet
is so when you hear this it is hardly
imaginable that Russia is preparing to
withdraw from the city so I think
they'll just um trying to win some time
some weeks when they have more forces
and run the weather with the winter
coming it will make it more difficult
for Ukraine to move forward forward
Jessica let me come to these claims
swirling around the hakovka dam
which is at a key a hydroelectric plant
you mentioned infrastructure earlier on
near Hassan president zielinski said
that his government has information that
the Russians have mined the structure
and Russia meanwhile is accusing Ukraine
of planning to attack the dam so are
these just verbal tactics designed to
throw the other side off balance or do
you think this discussion signals a
major escalation in the offing was a bit
of both of course it's part of the
information War but it undermines the it
shows the undermining of the Russian
military tactically if Russia is needing
to destroy infrastructure if they're
threatening to uh if they're putting out
rumors of dirty bombs or threatening the
dam which of course would not only
destroy a major power source but would
also flood an area where hundreds of
thousands of people live this would be a
catastrophic attack if this
infrastructure were destroyed they're
showing that tactically on the
battlefield they're weakened and
therefore needing to use these kinds of
threats to try to get Western support to
back off this is really what's what's
going on at play so it is a credible
threat it is something we have to take
seriously but it's also something that's
being used to shape The Narrative of
fear and deterrence in this war because
of staying with uh the Strategic and
tactical side here destroying the dam
would create major flooding as we heard
in the report and as Jessica has pointed
out it would also destroy an important
power plant put it utterly out of
commission who would have any real
strategic Advantage uh from that given
the fact that the Russians are the
occupiers don't they also need this damn
and this power plant to remain uh in
operation the Russians don't need the
power plant uh but they need the dam for
the water for Crimea that the channel
That supplies Crimea is uh is built from
that Reservoir as long as water levels
are high enough you can tap water and
pump it or let it flow downwards to to
Crimea
so they will not destroy it unless they
feel they have to of course if they
completely lose the Battle of Cresson if
there's sort of things are Beyond repair
for the Russian army they might explode
it just to
to drown a lot of Ukrainian soldiers and
to drown Ukrainian assault forces
equipped with heavy equipment which for
Ukraine is irreplaceable tanks are
irreplaceable because they get none from
the West infantry fighting vehicles are
irreplaceable so so there is a military
purpose they would also drown some of
their own Defenders but if you know if
the situation is lost they don't mind
for that
the concern arising due to the war of
words over the dam pales in comparison
to unease over Russia's nuclear muscle
flexing Russian defense minister Sergey
shoigu recently called his counterparts
in the U.S France and turkey to voice
his alarm about what he called possible
provocations by Kiev involving we just
heard it mentioned the use of a dirty
bomb that is a bomb laced with
radioactive substances that Kiev would
then seek to blame on Russia
we have concrete information about those
institutions in Ukraine their scientific
institutions that are capable of
creating this very dirty bomb
the information we have verified through
the appropriate channels is that this is
not a groundless accusation
if Russia calls and says that Ukraine is
allegedly preparing something it means
one thing Russia has already prepared
all this
I believe that the world should react as
harshly as possible now if Russia
continues to up the ante and prepare for
the next level of escalation it must
recognize that the world will not allow
it is
good stuff before we start talking about
all what about what this means just tell
us please what exactly is a dirty bomb
and what kind of harm could it cause a
dirty bomb is a conventional bomb
basically explosives and the Splinter
filler is not metal to cause physical
damage it's made up composed of
radioactive material that will then
spread in the immediate environment
where the bomb is detonated
it's a usually it is intended as a
terrorist weapon it has no military
value it has no destructive potential it
has and no impact on military operations
as such it would be like a Minefield it
would block a certain terrain for
movements but that's it would it leave a
radioactive effect that would
essentially make that zone uninhabitable
or unusable for sometimes it would make
a certain Zone unusable of course it
depends on the size on the composition
on the way it is detonated on the
altitude security is detonated but it
would basically make a smaller area are
uninhabitable but that's it it's of
course the long-term effects are worse
than the Minefield because it's easier
to clear a Minefield but the immediate
military effect is that of a Minefield
so next fact-based question is there any
evidence that Ukraine does have such a
weapon and might be planning to use it
this is all bogus nonsense
there is no preparation for making a
such a bomb and it would make absolutely
zero military sense for you Ukraine to
even think about that it is complete
propaganda and yeah and Jessica what do
you think about Russia might they have a
dirty bomb and might they be considering
using it it wouldn't be the first time
that Russia has accused someone else of
doing something that in fact it uh
itself uh plans to do and we do know
Russia just conducted a military drill
simulating a response to a nuclear
attack but that in fact included uh a
nuclear uh strike uh in response so what
do you think well precisely as Gustav
said the the proposition
from lavrov that Ukraine would be doing
this and planning this is completely
farcical it's complete bollocks but from
the Russian side this is a signal this
is a threat we have these in our arsenal
we would be willing to use them at the
end of the day this is a further sign of
the weakness of the Russian position on
the battlefield this threat is meant to
change the narrative and to move the
fear of Western governments and Western
voters to try to reduce support for
Ukraine it's another classic example of
Russia pushing a lie some fantastic
nonsense into the media then it gets
picked up reported on discussed doesn't
mean it do they not and they create in
this way and help shape the narratives
across the world but what we actually
need to see here is that this is another
lie another threat from a government
whose word has become meaningless so
let's talk about what effect that
narrative is having Roman uh how are
people people in Ukraine reacting to
poutine playing and and of course his
henchmen playing the fear card
well um people remain calm but still
they are worried and for the first time
since the beginning of this War I saw
that people really think that it is
possible for Russia to use nuclear
weapons against Ukraine something people
denied in the beginning they didn't
believe it can happen but um after
Russia annexed those four regions of
Ukraine two in the East and two in the
South
um after Russians threatened to use
um all it can including nuclear weapons
if Ukraine continues to fight on the
territory which Russia now believes is
Russian so people were discussing this
they were thinking about their plans
what they would do how they would
protect their children their families
the government made some some remarks on
that and said stay calm but you should
know what to do there were preparations
of shelters in Ukrainian cities for that
case but still on the large scale I
would say that Ukrainian remain rather
skeptical they don't believe that Russia
would do such a thing because it is too
dangerous for Russia itself Russia is
not so far away and to detonate a
nuclear bomb or to bomb Ukraine with a
nuclear weapon be it a tactical weapon
or any other kind
um it would mean it is too high a risk
for Russia itself or its neighbor
Belarus
agree with that assessment as he
mentioned uh Vladimir Putin has said
that he is prepared to use any weapon in
Russia's Arsenal to defend Russian
territory and now that he has annexed
her son and several other regions he
considers those to be Russian territory
on the other hand U.S intelligence
Services say that they do not see
evidence that Russia's nuclear posture
has changed so what are you expecting to
the extent that you can assess
while at second U.S assessment we have
very closely watched the preparation of
the nounuclear exercises we've very
closely watched a test of a nuclear
drone Russia has tested in the previous
month and we could very well trace the
movements of visible material of
reactor cores Etc so we know when Russia
moves something and if Russia moves
something we can pick up or the
Americans can pick up the red telephone
and make a call
but Russia will make nuclear noise and
it does so because it knows that this is
the only convincing argument they can
make to deter the west from supporting
Ukraine and unfortunately we are
providing them with evidence that this
augment works
Chancellor Schultz himself said numerous
times that he doesn't want to lead
Germany into World War that world war
needs to be avoided he is succumbing to
the fear card Biden himself did that he
has a very very untalented wording in
his own articles and speeches uh there
are there is noise in the white house
that is to be taken sort of that the
Americans are even taking is much too
seriously and that we give too much room
to this kind of intimidation
they see the Russians see that we still
hold back decisive military equipment
for Ukraine so they see that the
fear-mongering works and so they do more
of that it works for them we heard
president zielinski there saying the
West must harshly react uh Jessica we
did hear uh President Biden saying that
he has communicated directly to the
Russians that it would be a grave
mistake in his words to resort to any
type of radioactive weapon we heard the
foreign Ministers of France the UK and
the U.S also is sending very clear
messages but is it enough
no those words need to be backed up with
hard actions more weapons for Ukraine
more offensive weapons for Ukraine they
need tanks they need more air defense
and the Western Partners need to give it
to them this is the only thing that
Putin will react to
he's watching the messaging coming out
of Washington out of Berlin out of
Brussels very closely and the speeches
have zero effect on him the only thing
that will change the dynamic in this war
and give Putin a same taste of some of
the fear and intimidation that he is so
successfully spreading across NATO is to
show that we are delivering results
quickly and that Western support will
help Ukraine secure a decisive Victory
within the coming year but unfortunately
the the speeches and the comments yes of
course it's important to say if you make
this step the results for you will be
catastrophic but we need to back that up
with action in real time and giving the
ukrainians the support they need to
stand up to the Russian offenses and a
further point just on this entire
narrative even the fact that that we are
now breaking apart and talking about the
Russian dirty bomb stories is this is a
part of showing how effective this
strategy is they in a way are able to
shape The Narrative of this war by
taking these kinds of proactive steps by
putting stories out there and we need to
become collectively across the
pro-ukraine alliance much more effective
in simply dismissing these these
statements out of hand but isn't that
also what we're doing when we media talk
about these issues don't we need to give
people the facts about for example what
a dirty bomb is and is not
sure break down the facts let people
know but I think the the leading Point
needs to be that we don't even give
lavrov the media air time when he's
putting this stuff out there that's it's
part of the problem we we're treating
the Russian narratives on equal footing
as the statements coming out of Kiev and
that's a mistake let me just bring in a
few viewer uh comments uh in the very
little remaining time that we have we
received several comments from YouTube
viewers in response to last week's show
for example this one at this point this
conflict is no longer about just Ukraine
it seeks to answer the basic questions
conditions with nuclear weapons
blackmail those Nations that don't and
you better believe China and North Korea
are watching this closely and another
viewer says this viewer is fintucks the
thought that letting Russia get its will
would make the West somehow safer or
make things better in general is
completely out of touch with reality
Roman
do you think that clearly these are
viewers who share the consensus here on
the panel but do you think that citizens
in the West can remain steadfast in in
view of the ruse that the Russians are
using
well most of them can yes there is a
minority which is susceptible to such
Russian propaganda but most of them can
and they will yes and very briefly to uh
our our guests here in the studio our
title was the roost with the dirty bomb
assigned to Putin's weakness gusta
weakness
absolutely quickness thank you very very
much to all of you for being with us uh
once again on to the point thanks to our
viewers for uh joining us and please do
check out our show on YouTube and send
us your comments we'd love to hear them
so please do share them below take care
and goodbye for now
[Music]